today marks the 70th anniversary of the  first atomic bomb test in the nevada  desert  it's explosive the u.s air force dropped  a plane a one kiloton bomb on frenchman  flats northwest of las vegas up at the  test site  between 1951 and 1992 the u.s military  detonated more than 900 atomic bombs  here in nevada  most of them though underground nate  well i don't know if you know this but a  lot of folks used to grab drinks and  hang out on  rooftops particularly there at atomic  liquors in downtown las vegas they would  have mushroom cloud parties  now atomic liquors opened 60 years ago  as virginia's cafe  it is the oldest freestanding bar in  town